I'm great and something extraordinary
that your son did such an amazing job
playing you I mean that's what I'm most
proud of you know more than having this
movie having strata Compton this that
now there is the fact that my son was
able to take our opportunity and run
with it and hopefully set itself up and
you know one of the greatest industries
in the world and you know I'm so proud
just as a father and oh yeah you know it
was a movie about NWA - how much did he
know like when he was doing scenes was
he gonna like you did this - yeah in the
hotel rooms you know some of them say
y'all was doing the most favorite scenes
- but he did no I mean cuz how old was
he when he knew the lyrics - Straight
Outta Compton that was young man you
know my kids - three years playing all
the time
and you know they would wrap it in
sensor itself you know just they were
like rap the list right out of Compton
crazy month named Ice Cube from this is
funny
Laurie you've got kids but none of them
have followed in your footsteps no
I mean they have proper job they all do
proper jobs yeah they all did a bit they
all tried it and we're good at it
actually I thought but but didn't want
to I I just think it's an amazing thing
to think of your son doing this because
I you know most men are in some version
trying to try to play their father
anyway you know either imaginary or real
they're trying to sort of play the role
of their father until they find out you
know if they ever do some some don't if
they ever find out who they are I think
that's just an incredible thing I mean I
had a Barry this is a very very sort of
mild version of it because I was playing
I spent almost ten years playing a
doctor and my father was a doctor and I
felt like I was I was a fake version of
what he really was and I felt always
sort of constantly guilty about that
because I think I think a lot of men do
actually grow up feeling like that
feeling like fake versions of their own
and until you hopefully get to a point
where you can think well I am I am the
real thing in some form you know it's
whatever it is it's real because I love
you how many kids have you got out 3 3
so if one of them or indeed all of them
came to you and says yeah we're going to
be an actor actress would you be
thrilled horrified it's quite hard thing
to answer cuz I love it I love my job
but I know I've been lucky so it'd be
quite hard for my kids to go into it and
be less lucky or yes so you wouldn't say
I'd like you to be a success for that
yeah they're also very clever they're
much cleverer than me so what's hard to
know with the baby with them
[Laughter]
you know my son my daughter my daughter
is just she's in love with what I do she
fully gets it my daughter is is 10 years
old and you know I'm big on letting my
kids see me in my work environment
whether it's on set whether it's on
stage tour I let them be around their
dad so they can really understand what I
do
my daughter sits like when I'm on stage
I don't let them donate allowed to watch
the first 7 to 10 minutes of my show cuz
that part's clean it gets filthy 10
minutes she just sits and she watches
and she mimics me in the house and my
daughter has got a tight five minutes
like introduce me like she's got this
she's got my mannerisms she comes out of
stage she's like what do you do wish
your job
[Laughter]
[Music]
let me educate you something black
people black people are notorious for
picking things that they saw one day and
say that's my baby name can't boycott
something that you never went to anyway
that's kind of weird not you know it's
uh I look at it as